Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P, this caller has a
really interesting question. Do these MAGA people
genuinely not understand what free speech means
or are they only pretending to question?
Speaker 2: Why does the right seem to
always complain about free speech when
they're talking about private companies?
Are they intentionally saying that because
they know that their audience doesn't really
know what free speech actually is? Right.
Or they themselves don't know what it means.
Speaker 1: Yeah, it could be either one.
This is a really great question. So often
these right wingers will say this is an issue of
the First Amendment. Even if it did, you see that
thing pop up? I don't know if that was just on
screen. A little clip related to one of my cables
just literally popped up like like a like a like
a jumping bean of some kind. I wonder if the video
caught that. We'll have to review the footage
later. Two different parts here. One, they often
say this is a First Amendment issue and it has
nothing to do with the government, the government
and the First Amendment. Related Twitter Doing
something not related to the First Amendment.
Secondly, do they know the difference between
free speech or moderation? It's not clear that
they do. I genuinely don't know the answer. There
are some slightly more informed right wingers
who understand the difference between free speech
and First Amendment and just moderation. But they
will say platforms like Twitter and Facebook have
become so large that they are essentially like a
town square and they should be regulated as if
they were government entities. Interestingly,
that's pretty heavy handed from the regulation
perspective. So at the end of the day, I don't
know what right wingers do and don't know. Are
they ignorant? Are they arguing in bad faith? Is
it some combination of the two? You be the judge.
We have a great bonus show for you today. We will
talk about the Elon Musk Twitter CEO situation.
We're going to talk about Madison Cawthorn being
sued by his own lawyers for not paying them. Seems
like that's going around in Trumpism. And we will
talk about Alex Jones salary request as part of
his bankruptcy proceedings. Wild, wacky request.
Sign up at join Packman dot com. Get instant
access to the world famous and award winning show.